while troops mass on either side of the
ukraine-russia border diplomats in nato
capitals and moscow are considering what
economic weapons they have at their
disposal nato allies have threatened
sanctions against russia including
banning russian financial institutions
from the global swift network that
proceeds five trillion dollars a day of
transactions america could also
unilaterally ban russian institutions
from settling dollar transactions via
the u.s federal reserve and washington
is also considering export controls on
products containing u.s developed
integrated circuit boards that could
choke off suppliers of everything from
weapon systems to consumer electronics
now all of these measures would be
damaging to the russian economy but
moscow has taken steps to reduce its
exposure to sanctions since they were
last used in earnest in 2014.
pushing's whole idea is that russia is a
besieged fortress surrounded by enemies
and that means he's really been pushing
self-sufficiency in terms of imports in
terms of financial dependence on the
outside world everything he needs in
order to withstand the sort of pain we
can inflict and he thinks that we can't
withstand the sort of pain that he can
inflate moscow's trump card in any
economic conflict will be natural gas
russia supplies around 35 percent of
europe's gas and currently much of it
comes via pipelines that cross ukraine
earning kiev valuable carriage fees now
moscow is desperate to start using a new
pipeline the nord stream 2 directly to
germany underneath the baltic it's
awaiting regulatory approval in berlin
but already ukraine has accused the
germans of betrayal now restricting gas
supplies will put further pressure on
european consumers and industry this
chart shows the huge spikes in gas
prices in the last year and these prices
are likely to remain high in the medium
term the uk is less directly exposed to
russian gas than our neighbours 47 of
our supply still comes from the north
sea 31
from european pipelines the bulk from
norway also belgium and holland and
ultimately just five percent from russia
the balance 22
is liquid natural gas imported largely
from qatar now that doesn't mean
conflict in ukraine will not have an
impact here the imf has warned that it
would force energy prices higher and
inflation will follow in global markets
no one is insulated from a revival of
cold war tensions